[Music]
you know ken our ratings uh on the show
have gone up substantially during these
wacky times because the um
and i have a i have a theory
on this have you noticed that the world
has gone nuts
yes
yes lost their minds out there
what is wrong with you people
yeah
so i mean yeah it's just uh uh it's a
thing and so
and and like we're still sane and stuff
oh yeah like you know like we believe in
like the truth and the law of gravity
still will cause you to hit the sidewalk
when you jump off a building and stuff
like that there are some things you can
believe in that are true and safe and
calm and kindness does matter
not just anger
and our pulse rate hasn't changed so
people are like why how how come they're
not scared over there at ramsey
solutions how come how come they're not
lost their minds
because we actually believe in solid
things and teach solid things and so
the great news about the stuff we teach
here whether it's in the career area the
mental health area the marriage area the
money area certainly is
it works in crazy times and it works in
regular times
and so i guess everybody went you know i
need some calmness in my life i need
some stability in my life i need an
anchor that is based on actual facts not
people just making up crap which seems
to be a thing
like you know the old joke was 88 of the
statistics are made up on the spot right
and so i think it's 98 but it's like
right now yeah
88 of science is made up on the spot so
um oh jesus christ went and did it i did
it i did it i went there
i did it so but i mean it's just and
people are lost they're dead kind of
number 11 yeah and you know we could
have said this exact same little rant
right here about
18 months ago and we've still been
accurate but yeah right now it's just
we're we have the second wave of crazy
coming through we went through the
pandemic
and now we're going through the economic
tsunami that is the delayed you know
when where does the tsunami come from an
earthquake way out in the ocean
so the pandemic was the earthquake way
out in the ocean now we've got supply
chain labor shortages
product shortages hyper inflation
you know stinking have you noticed the
price of your gasoline going into your
car five dollars a gallon today in new
york five dollars a gallon and i saw
another headline and they don't even
drive there no they don't they don't uh
you know it's interesting what we talk
about here at ramsey solutions whatever
category that you just listed out the
reality is is that when you've got
discipline when you've got a plan when
the crazy times hit and they will
you don't have to go crazy but everybody
else is going crazy because they weren't
ready for it they don't know what to do
they don't know how to get out of it and
you're right it is a very interesting
time right now where there are some
people dave that are trying to elongate
the panic i got my existential crisis
out of the way about 30 years ago so i'm
kind of i kind of got that one in my
rearview mirror i went ahead and had my
mid-life crisis early
and so um i was always an overachiever
so i raised the bar so high just like i
was 27 years old so i mean i went broke
lost everything the kids you know i
couldn't feed the kids and i lost my
mind and i didn't know what i was gonna
do and so that's all kind of back there
ways and so i'm kind of like some of
this other stuff hits i just yawn now
i'm like oh is that all it is here's
something i've i've never asked you on
the show and i want to ask you because
it's really relevant
do you notice a difference between the
headlines and what you see every day we
travel the country
still
we live here in tennessee
i just see a huge disparity between what
we're being told is going on versus what
i see every day do you sense that
well i've been in five states in 15 days
just recently i mean in the last 15
years i've been traveling we were doing
stuff with radio i was doing stuff with
uh when i spoke at liberty university
and so
um
yeah i i and i'm sad to say
that both sides of the media because
there's not like a media anymore there's
the right media and the left media
and uh they both lie
all the time
uh if it bleeds it leads
you know and so
i you know the right hand media is
telling you that you know that you if
you go to california it's all shut down
and the governor is a you know whatever
and the whole the whole thing i went out
to orange county and it was like nothing
going on that's what i'm talking walking
around normal and yeah i went to
restaurants and a couple of servers had
masks on but i mean it was about like it
is here in nashville and
you know
fewer rednecks but i mean it's just but
it was um
but it was just i mean it was like i
expected based on the news media to
think i was going to russia right you
know the right-hand news media and of
course the left-hand news media would
have you believe that we're all going to
die tomorrow
and so you might as well get you know
whatever living you have left out of the
way because friday's coming and so um
but i mean and you know and i don't see
that out there either
that's my point
i i just
i quit watching them i i some a lot of
them are friends of mine that's good and
i i just had to turn them off because my
old friend zig ziglar used to say he
said i get up every morning i read the
bible read the newspaper so i can tell
what both sides are doing
so good classic classic ziggler but he's
right you know it's like if you can't
inputs will screw up your mind
yeah and uh and you join the crazy you
join the fray right i got a friend of
mine watching cnn and fox right we're
gonna have to put the boy in a rubber
room he's gonna lose it he's gonna he's
it's just gonna well his brain is
draining out of his ears so what you
watch what you listen to
who you listen to who you hang out with
dramatically affect our decisions so
some of this crazy is a result of we're
paying attention to the wrong things
crazy to the wrong things yeah it's like
step off the
crazy people are in charge that's the
problem who knew
let's see that's that's the myth too
they're not in charge
i mean there's all kinds of nonsense
going on in dc right now every day well
that's asking yourself how does that
affect your day-to-day life
get off of the crazy merry-go-round and
realize you have a lot to do with you
yeah a lot more than you realize it it
affected me when i went to the gas pump
sure of course it affected me a few
other times but overall
other than that it didn't really affect
me except to the extent i chose to
cram this trashy input into my brain
every day
and then try to exist in a normal world
the only time i got nervous dave
was when the toilet paper got got dicey
that was that was a little scary got up
to the old neighborhood grocery store
couldn't find any toilet paper i just
officially got nervous that was the only
time shook me for about 10 minutes and
then i realized
we'll adjust and then i got over it
aren't you glad i shared that with you
yeah and you have to know that if the
biggest crisis that you've had in your
life was tp you're blessed you're in
pretty good shape buddy
you're just pretty good shape i'm just
saying everything that's the best
everybody daniel boone didn't have tps
and he made it which is why i adjusted
it after 10 minutes davey crockett they
figured it out no tp but he figured out
a way didn't have american express he
left home without it